Welcome to the Joe show the show where we give you tips and tricks on how to
land a successful career. In tech, the last video,
I talked about how I got my first internship, which was at Scotiabank,
and I promised that I will make further ones about different internships.
So this is the second internship I had. It is at Citadel. Oh yeah.
I just want to say shout out for the people who, um, told me to,
to make this video.
I guess a little bit of context before I was a software engineer or my first
year in university of Waterloo,
I actually did not want to be a software engineer. I want to work in finance,
but you know,
you'll see later on why became more of a software kind of guy than a finance
guy. And it's kind of it's because of Citadel actually.
And it was without further ado. Let's.
I just want to start over.
By talking about the benefits.
Citadel not going to lie was my highest paid
internship out of all the other ones. So what I got,
I think I had 7,800
$7,800 a month.
So it's kind of like $45 an hour.
You can say if you work 40 hours a week, and then you also had free housing,
I had a, I had a studio apartment and it was kind of like a penthouse.
It wasn't really a penthouse, but basically you had like, you know,
full windows and you could see the Lake and stuff. And it was amazing.
The view was beautiful. It was gorgeous. They get lunch, breakfast and dinner.
So you get to eat there if you want. Yeah. So out of all the internships,
this one probably paid the most.
If we combined all the benefits and the monthly pay together. So yeah,
it was a pretty good internship. So, all right.
Let's get to how I got the job in the first place. So remember,
last time I said, I went to university of Waterloo,
so I was in co-op and then this was my second co-op term.
So I did the same thing. I did a ranking. Uh,
basically what happens in ranking is you applied to a lot of jobs and then later
on you could see if employers want you, or did they rank you when he rank you?
It means they don't want you to, like, they're not,
you're not the number one choice,
but if the number one choice does not want the job, you might get the job.
So that's how you order the worst. Let's look at my resume. Let's look, uh,
let's look at what I did. Okay. So as you can see, still using my old,
late tech format. So I got my first job experience,
which is that Scotia capital from the previous video. But I think what got me,
the job was actually my personal project and just how I
aligned with like the finance slash software type of guy.
So I'll show you what it is. So here, as you can see prediction trading bot,
this was the project I talked about last time.
They really liked that because it's really the finance and it shows that you can
code, you know, it shows I can code Python and I'm scrappy. And basically,
you know, I could make something that runs and it doesn't die. So next project,
ramen international training competition. I think this one mattered too.
Not because it showed my coding skills,
but it showed because I care about finance and at least I would have like, um,
you know, context,
like finance context so that they don't need to re-explain everything.
But to be honest,
most software engineering jobs in finance or like technical jobs in finance,
they don't care if you don't know anything about finance,
because they think they can teach you. They know they can teach you, you know,
finance stuff is easy,
but the technical skills that's kind of hard to teach and it requires more
resources for them.
They usually prioritize you knowing your technical stuff really well,
rather than you knowing your finance stuff. And then the other project, uh,
smash player database. Uh, yeah, I used to be really into super smash Emilia.
And what I did was I was really into,
I was into like a Toronto community or I used to play competitive smash a lot.
I wasn't really good. I never got out of the pools, but I mean,
like if I play against a casual player, I'll probably beat the out of them,
but I was really interested in like ranking players.
I want to see who's actually better than who, so I won.
So I made it like an ELO kind of thing where you could input, like,
who'd you play it against and then, you know, using ELO, calculate your ranking.
And that's like the first time that I learned how to make like a website that
has like, could, you know, create, read, update, delete, and stuff like that.
But I used PHP, which is like, like very old school,
but at least, you know, I learned the fundamentals and then yeah,
CRC robotics I've had talked about last time and I kept in my resume. So yeah.
So that was my resume going in. All right. So let's talk about the interview.
So how it worked.
I had two phone interviews and then one onsite and on the onsite I had three
interviews. So the first phone interview was, uh, it was pretty easy,
cause it was a fit question. Basically,
you talked with the recruiter and you talk about, Oh,
why do you want to join Citadel? What have you done in the past? You know,
what do you know about finance?
So I thought she really liked me because I showed a lot of passion, passion.
And then I also talked about my technical skills and how like, you know,
I have a CS degree, I learned C plus plus,
which is perfect because a lot of their code base are in C plus plus.
And the reason for that is because, you know, it's high performance, you know,
they write, you know, really high-performing code, you know,
so they love it. They like that. The fact that I use C plus plus the most.
So the second one, yeah. Interview is a technical one.
I don't quite remember exactly what it was because it was four years ago.
But I do remember that I did not code cause we didn't open code Pat or anything.
He was asking me a lot of like theoretical question or computer science
question. I remembered it was a question asking about imagined or multiple,
you know, it's, it's something related to this,
but multiple threads wanting to change your database,
like how would you make sure that, you know,
you don't have like corruption of data,
like imagine if you need to update one row and another row,
but then at the same time, another guy's updating a row like transactions.
So what would you do? So then you have to talk about the concept of locks.
They want to make sure that you understand what locks are,
because I think you work with it a lot in, at Citadel or at least my team.
I was pretty surprised that I got the on-site interview because I didn't think
my phone interview went that well, because I don't know.
I was scared that he saw through my and I didn't know what the I was talking
about when I was talking about locks and stuff. But you know,
I guess I tricked him because I got an onsite. Now,
funny thing about the onsite. This is, this is a funny story. Um,
one 40 onsite, uh, before going there, I went to Montreal first.
Cause that's where I lived all the other candidates that had an onsite.
They went from either Toronto Waterloo. So they took the same, uh,
they took the same plane. I was the only one that was taking it from Montreal.
So the funny thing is when I went there for my onsite,
no one else from my school was there, no one I Waterloo was present.
So then I was like, Oh. Then I just get like lucky.
And then I probably just got the job because I was the only candidate.
That's not true because apparently they, they flew them out later on.
But I do think that me being there first had an advantage somehow.
And then the interview process, it was, um,
you do three interviews during the day, the first interview,
this guy was more of a probability kind of guy.
So this guy asked me like two brain teasers and like one probability question or
it was like two probably questions, one brain teaser.
And then the second interview, second interview was, I think it was a hard one.
This interview, I would call it like C plus plus theory or something like that.
Basically it asked like, what is the order of like deletion? And so far,
it was very successful as related. And then I think he asked me about locks too,
like how it works or like semaphores so make sure, you know, your,
your C plus plus theory or I guess like, you know, concurrency stuff.
Cause I think that's really important,
especially in like a high-frequency kind of firm. And then the third one,
the third one was pretty chill. Uh, the third,
almost like a classic classic interview where, you know,
first he would ask you to, you know, make a class of design,
to design a class that was served a certain purpose.
And that purpose for me was like, imagine you have a, you have a portfolio, uh,
what would you want to keep? And then after that, after I designed the class,
the second question was like a simple coding question.
I was pretty excited and I thought I did all right,
but I didn't have any expectations because I didn't want to keep my hopes up.
But when I went home, they called me and they said like, Oh, you know, we,
everyone liked to, uh, we want you to work for us and here's the offer.
And during that time I had other offers too. For example,
I was thinking about going to Bloomberg because I also got an offer at
Bloomberg, but I was pretty happy that I'd been accepted because you know,
like Citadel ended up being a lot higher in pay. So that's cool.
Let me show you, um,
what my job offer or like the ranking looks like in Waterloo in case
some of you do I'm wearing the Waterloo shirt, but anyways,
in case some of you want to, in case some of you want to,
you know, maybe join Waterloo in the future is what it looks like. Uh Oh, okay.
Yeah. So here you can see the job titles employers,
and when it says offer, it means they offered you. And when it says ranked,
it means that you're not the best candidate,
but if the other people don't take you, then I'll take you.
So this is how it looks like, get you interviewed, like,
those were the only interviews I got,
I got 10 interviews and then five of them accepted me. So yeah.
So then that's how, that's how it works. Okay.
I guess I'll talk about how it was at Citadel. Um,
I worked at the options market making team, so it was a,
it was pretty coding intensive because you know, it's like high frequency. It's,
uh, it feels more of a business than kind of like gambling because some teams,
you know, they just gamble on oil or like they just gamble on certain assets,
but like market-making was like, you have, you know,
you have regulations and then you have deals with the exchanges.
So, you know, it feels like if it was more of a business and like, uh, you know,
low risk kind of, um, kind of team. So yeah, so the work we worked,
decently hard, people work pretty late, um, compared to Facebook, you know,
it's around the same. I feel like it's not crazy when I worked there. Um,
I mostly worked on their C plus plus code base.
So it was a lot of C plus plus I learned a lot actually before this internship,
I didn't know about anything because of this internship.
I learned about networking, you know, TCP, UDP kind of thing. I learned about,
you know, OS stuff I learned about processes.
I learned about multithreading I learned about locks semaphores and all these
good stuff.
So this was a very good internship because I learned a lot about like CS
fundamentals and then it made school like a lot easier.
So like an example of what I did there, I probably can't say much,
but in some ways I roll my own web server, you know, like I'm not saying like,
Oh, you just install no JS and put express and stuff like that. No,
I actually wrote like a server that receives a TCP connection and then receive
HTTP request response, and then follows the www like,
um, specification and then receive that.
And then I spit out a string back to that. So it was very low level.
And in addition to that, I also wrote my own web socket layer.
So I don't know if you guys know what that is, but like it's pretty popular now.
So I'm pretty sure you guys know what web sockets are,
but basically instead of using the HTP requests, you could do a web socket,
which means it's actually one TCP connection with the server that does not get
killed. And you send messages to each other is actually old technology,
you know, because how HTP works is like you send the HTP request.
So that means you open a TCP connection,
you send the thing and then you close it to speak connection.
And then when you send another HP connection, you do it again. You close it.
So there's a lot of overhead web socket takes care of that.
It's just one connection stays on and you send message to each other. Next time.
I see you,
I'll be talking about LinkedIn and how I got a software engineering internship
there. So if you want to see what's going to happen or how I got that job,
don't forget to like.
Ooh, I forgot to mention the startup series. Yeah, it's still going on.
Don't worry about it. The next episode is coming real soon.